well for more I'm joined from Montreal
by The evolutionary behavioral scientist
and author Professor Gad sad Gad uh it's
heartbreaking I mean I as I came on air
tonight I heard the story of of uh
allegedly know it's not been completely
verified but there are soldiers
reporting that in one Village they found
the corpses of 40 babies some of whom
have been
beheaded uh and we know that uh
grandmothers who survived the Holocaust
would dragged off and kidnapped and God
knows what's happened to them uh these
are unspeakable acts of
depravity what is your reaction to this
well of course I'm uh devastated by it
but frankly not to sound uh flippant
about it it doesn't surprise me for your
viewers and listeners who may know me I
hail from Lebanon we're Lebanese Jews
when I was 5 years old in 1970 in
Lebanon and Gamal abdan Naser the
president of Egypt died the way that the
people on the street Street were uh
mourning his loss were was to have
demonstrations singing death to Jews
what did the Jews have to do with the
fact that the Egyptian president had
just died when I was in grade four and
the teacher said everybody stand up and
say what you want to be when you grow up
one of my friends with whom I played
soccer stood up and said when I grow up
I want to be a Jew killer when we left
Lebanon to move to Canada during the
Civil War and the can Canadian the pilot
had said that we are now out of Lebanese
airspace my mother put a star of David
around my neck and said now you don't
have to hide your identity and you can
be proud of you who you are so this has
nothing to do with colonialism and
fighting for this piece of land or that
piece of land it's an existential battle
where one group of folks don't believe
that the other group has a right to
exists there with self-determination
once we get rid of that mindset there
could be peace I mean I I got to say I
don't think peace has ever looked
further away uh in this conflict I
really think the scale of this atrocity
is so appalling that it will demand
probably a disproportionate response now
from Israel I don't think prime minister
Netanyahu will feel he has any choice
but to hit Palestine harder than it's
ever been hit and of course that will
cause the death deaths of many thousands
of completely innocent people many of
who may share a view that Hamas are a
bunch of terrorists uh and so it goes on
I just don't see how peace gets forged
after this kind of thing I I agree look
I'm a by Nature by disposition I'm an
optimistic person but I get a lot of
calls and emails from people saying to
me will there ever be peace and I I hate
to admit but I think I share your uh
your view and again it comes from the
fact that there is one group of folks
who do not believe that another group of
folks have a right to self determination
sure they can tolerate them sure they
could have them as second class citizens
as demies that's an Arabic word for
second class citizen who's protected and
tolerated of course until you're not but
they don't view the Jews as a people who
are allowed to exist with their own
individual Nation self-determination
autonomy and until that is resolved this
is going to go on at infinum I want to
play a clip now this is from President
Biden speaking just a few minutes ago uh
in the United States that the United
States stands with Israel we will not
ever fail to have their back we'll make
sure that they have the help their
Citizens need and they can continue to
defend themselves Israel has the right
to defend itself and its people full
stop there's never justification for
terrorist attacks and my
administration's support for Israel's
security is Rock Solid and
unwavering I mean Gad you know strong
words there from President Biden it's
taken him a few days to say them I have
to say um I guess the problem I have
with this
is Israel is going to go in like I said
incredibly hard into Gaza I I imagine
many thousands of people are going to
die here uh the situation in Gaza will
simply get worse it's already pretty
intolerable for the 2 million people who
live there many of whom are young people
who live
really hopeless lives with very little
chance of ever getting out of living the
dreams that most people have you know I
understand on the Palestinian side why
they have felt oppressed I understand it
um I don't think you can play water
bouty at this moment after this atrocity
and it doesn't excuse the appalling
depravity that's been perpetrated by
Hamas but I do understand why people in
palese feel oppressed and I don't know
how this resolves
itself in the the short to midterm or
indeed longterm and and I hate that
feeling of helplessness about this well
it resolves itself when your moral
calculus is outraged whenever any
innocent is butchered in any place right
so when I watched videos of Isis taking
1,500 Muslim men and putting bullets in
their head I was Furious I was angry I
didn't have a tribal calculus that says
I am Jewish so who cares if Isis kills
Muslim men so if I see a Palestinian
child who is a complete innocent
bystander in the war who is you know
blown up I'm angry by the same token if
you're seeing Holocaust Survivors and
Jewish babies being decapitated then boy
is your moral compass broken if you
can't Garner a bit of kindness and
sympathy for their plight I completely
agree uh Gad you speak so much sense as
always great to talk to you thank you
very much thank you sir well join me now
as a man many of us know as a famous
television personality he's also a
former Israeli paratrooper who fought
him the 1967 Six Day War and he's a
long-term friend of Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and that's
URI
gella URI great to talk to you I wish it
had been in happier circumstance we've
talked many times over the years uh what
is your response to what has happened
here okay Pierce first of all thank you
very much for inviting me onto your show
and I would like to correct you because
over
1,200 people were slaughtered and you
said it children babies elderly women
men you know what dogs were shot dogs
pets were
shot I mean I'm I'm outraged and I would
like to say that over 3,500 people are
injured
maimed who how who knows how many tens
of thousands are psychologically hurt
physically inside their mind they will
never forget this and I would like to
mention this is very important that this
is the worst tragedy to happen to the
Jewish people since a holocaust just
think about that the number of Israeli
deaths is equivalent now listen to this
to ask if
36,000 people were killed in a single
attack in America and there's no doubt
Iran is behind the attack you know even
if we don't have yet solid proof there
is no doubt that Iran made the
conditions the right conditions for this
attack to be possible and exactly the
same way as Hitler made the Holocaust
possible I am outraged I'm angry like
the millions of Israelis are angry how
could this have happened let me ask you
I call this first of all let me let me
ask ask you I I completely agree I share
I share your outrage here um and it can
only be immeasurably worse if you're
Jewish if you live in Israel it must be
immeasurably worse and I completely
accept that I want to just put aside
this atrocity for a moment and I want to
talk about the historic conflict and I
want to ask you how does this ever get
resolved I mean the the scale of what's
happened here is so heinous that I don't
have any hope that it can be resolved
anytime soon but before that what would
you have said last week about the the
way this ever gets
resolved well Pierce look I'm I'm not a
historian um whether you're asking me
this question as an Israeli or as a
psychic or to predict how this will be
solved as an Israeli really nobody knows
yet I I'm an optimist I'm a positive
thinker I want to believe that um after
this war is finished and God knows where
this war is going to take us but um I do
believe in diplomacy I do believe in
negotiations and I think in the long
long run because I'm an optimist I
believe that there will be
peace there has to be peace what do you
feel let me ask you what what do you
feel about the the plight of the
Palestinian people going back decades
now I mean there can be no disputing the
fact that 2 million people live in
appalling conditions there very few are
able to get out of there um their
conditions have just now obviously got
10 times worse and many will say well
good they deserve it but many of them
are completely innocent people uh their
women children will get killed as well
in this process and I just wonder what
how do you deal with Gaza I mean what
what happens there okay look you know
again tragically after this massacre the
gloves are all off they have to be off
otherwise this will never never ever
stop look I feel for the Palestinian
people especially for the children
children are being hurt on both sides
you know ironically believe it or not I
am connected I support a a worldwide
charity that is based in Israel called
save a child's heart they we've saved
over 7,000 children with open heart
surgery do you want to believe this that
half of them are Palestinians
half of the kids we saved are
Palestinians so it's very difficult for
me to predict how this is going to be
sold look we have to go back I mean in
history thousands of years we the Jewish
people escaped Egypt I mean we're
prosecuted for not decades but not
hundreds of years but thousands of years
and this is one part of this frenzy of
war that is happening Happ and is
creating chaos not only in the Middle
East but probably around the world look
let me bring back the Iranians you know
for for the Iranians now this gives time
to continue building the nuclear bomb a
nuclear bomb in the hands of Iran I mean
that's deadly worldwide I don't have to
tell you Piers what would happen if a
nuclear bomb explodes in Europe forget
it forget it the whole world radiation
travels in air in W with wind it's
deadly and we have to focus not only on
this immediate conflict now but we have
to make sure Iran does not get the
nuclear bomb I agree and I think I think
it run I think although there's not been
established Beyond doubt yet I think
it's pretty obvious that Hamas could not
have carried out something of this scale
without the help of of Iran in terms of
training in terms of funding in terms of
all of it and and they remain a a a
global Menace and must be treated as
such I I've got to leave it there thank
you very much indeed for joining me as I
said I wish it very much and God bless
you all I wish it was in better
circumstance and uh my thoughts with
everybody over where you are thank you
very
much